In the last few videos, I showed
you amines, and, in
particular, it was ethylamine,
involved in Sn2 reactions.
But what I want to show you in
this video, it doesn't always
have to be an Sn2 reaction.
In fact, in this video, we'll
look at an Sn1 reaction.
So let's say I had
some methylamine.
So let's say it looks
like this.
So this is our methyl group
bonded to a nitrogen, which is
bonded to two hydrogens,
just like that, and it
has its lone pair.
So this is methylamine
right there.
And let's say it's in solution
with something
that looks like this.
Let's say we have something
So then we have a bromo group.
Now, there's a couple of
different ways that you can
name this, but maybe the
simplest way, you find the
longest chain here.
It has one, two, three carbons,
so that is a propane.
And then on the two carbon,
regardless of whether you
start counting from here or
there, so this is one, two,
three, on the two carbon, you
have a bromo group and you
have a methyl group
right there.
So this would be 2-bromo.
You want to write it in
alphabetical order.
2-bromo-2-methylpropane.
What we care about is what
would happen over here?
Now, over here, you have a
situation where you have a
carbon right here attached
to the bromine.
And if your brain is really in
Sn2 mode, you might say, hey,
maybe these electrons attack
this carbon and then this
electron that's with the carbon
right now gets taken by
the bromine.
But if you really think about
what are the conditions for an
Sn2, you'll probably remember
that this won't happen because
it's sterically hindered.
You have these three
other carbons here.
And actually, these are not just
carbons, these are CH3's.
The hydrogens aren't
even drawn.
But this is a CH3 here.
This is a CH3 over here.
This is a CH3.
These things are going to block
the nucleophile's access
to this carbon, so you're
not going to see an
Sn2 reaction here.
But what you can see is, because
this guy is a tertiary
carbon, he is bonded to three
other carbons, it would
actually be a fairly
stable carbocation.
So what you could see in step
one of this reaction is just
the bromine leaves.
So if you have just the bromine
leaves, then our
situation looks like this.
You have a tertiary
carbocation.
This electron leaves, so it
now has a positive charge
right over there.
That's why it's a
carbocation now.
And now the bromine has
taken an electron.
It already had one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
valence electrons.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
And it just took one more
electron from that carbon.
It now has a negative charge.
It's now a bromide anion.
But now that the bromine has
left, now the methylamine can
get involved.
This would be methylamine
right over here.
So now this, as we learned in
the previous video, has a
partial negative charge, has
these extra electrons, it will
be attracted to this
carbocation.
So let me draw the
methylamine.
So you have the nitrogen,
hydrogen, hydrogen bonded to a
methyl group right like that.
And in an Sn1 reaction,
that's what this is.
Remember, the rate-determining
step right here only involves
one of the reactants.
That's where the number
one comes from.
In an Sn1 reaction like this,
the nucleophile could attack
from either side.
This no longer is a
tetrahedral shape.
It's now a triangular planar
shape, so it could go in from
this direction or from
that direction.
So, in this case, well,
I'm just going to
draw it in this direction.
So this nucleophile can give
this electron right here to
the carbocation, in which case,
we will end up with
something that looks
like this.
We have our nitrogen.
It has bonded to two hydrogens
over there.
It has a methyl group,
just like that.
It has this electron
over here.
Now, this magenta electron has
been given to this carbon over
there, and then that carbon is
bonded to three other carbons:
one, two, three.
And so, just like that,
we have created--
oh, we have to remember.
We've given away an electron
to this carbocation.
The carbocation is
now neutral.
It gained an electron.
Let me write the the
carbon right there.
But since the nitrogen gave away
an electron, it now has a
positive charge.
So what will we call this
molecule right over here?
Now, this is a little
bit tricky.
So you have a methyl
group over here.
Well, this is no longer amine.
It's an ammonium because it
has this positive charge.
We have four bonds
on the nitrogen.
So we could call this
right here N-methyl.
That tells us that the methyl
is bonded to the nitrogen.
It's not bonded to the
other carbon chain.
N-methyl.
And then this right here, these
four carbons, one, two,
three, four, this you could view
as a tert-butyl group.
There's other ways to
name it, but that's
the most common one.
So it's N-methyl-tert-butyl
ammonium.
Remember, we have that positive
charge there.
And as we saw in the previous
video, this isn't ammonium
right now, but you had some of
your original methylamine
floating around.
If you have some of your
original methylamine floating
around, and this could in
theory, or it can in practice
even, nab away one of these
hydrogens, or at least the
proton part.
So it gives its electron to that
hydrogen, and then the
hydrogen's electron gets taken
back by what was an ammonium.
And then if you have
that-- and this is
a reversible reaction.
It can go in either direction.
This methylamine is now
methyl ammonium.
So it now looks like this.
It now has three hydrogens on
it because this guy bonded
with that hydrogen.
It now has three hydrogens, so
this is methyl ammonium.
And then this thing over here
will now look like this.
It lost a hydrogen.
So you have a methyl group
bonded to an N, bonded to an
H, which is then bonded
to a tert-butyl group.
So now this has become,
as I just said,
this is methyl ammonium.
But this over here
is N-methyl.
Once again, the N tells us
that this methyl group is
bonded to the nitrogen.
N-methyl-tert-, and now instead
of calling it butyl
ammonium, and actually we didn't
have to have this dash
over here; this is
butyl ammonium.
It's now butylamine, tert-butyl,
and then obviously
because we have that nitrogen
there, butylamine.
Anyway, I just wanted to show
you that, that the mechanisms
or the reactions I showed in
the last video, they're not
the only type of things
that can occur.
You can also have Sn1.
And, in general, it can
act as a weak base.
It's definitely not
a strong base.
But it's the most basic of all
of the neutral functional
groups, which I've said
over and over again.
So there's many different
types of reactions.
I've just tried to give
you a sample of a few.